I'm taking the aroma clear, the astro clear, and the sulfur as I have had good
blood tests for the last two years. I'm 75 years old. Recently I read that
there's some natural progesterone cream made from yams. Would this be a good
thing to put on? Do you think this would be helpful for you to do? Why or why not?
So if a person has, let's say they have colon cancer, let's say they have, you know,
brain cancer. Let's say they have a cancer that any cancer that is not
hormonally driven in any way or has a chance to be in hormonally driven, then
you're fine using progesterone cream. If you have a cancer that is hormonally
driven, then you do not want to use progesterone cream because progesterone will
store in the cells and will aromatize into estrogen. So you do not want to use
progesterone cream if you have a hormonally driven cancer.